[Music]  Britney Spears and boyfriend  Samus Gauri make their red carpet debut  the 37 year old singer and her fitness  model Bo packed on the PDA during their  date night on Monday at the once upon a  time and Hollywood premiere in Los  Angeles Britt stunned in a new key  red-hot mini dress and black chunky  heels while Sam looked dapper in a  cream-colored suit white shirt and dark  tie you better work [ __ ] although this  marks the couple's first carpet together  the pair haven't been shy about showing  their relationship on social media Britt  bruh and Sam often post sweet pics and  videos together packing on the PDA  swirling into each others arms riding  bikes and of course working out  [Music]  kind of keeps you really strong proving  at time and time again they're total  couple goals I'm just a normal girl